si au psg il est souvent question de
compétition et de transfert en dehors du
terrain en ce moment c'est surtout un
parfum d'amour qui semble enivrer les
joueurs stars du club depuis quelques
temps neymar semblent plus amoureux que
jamais au bras de la mannequin natalia
baroux leach une jeune femme qui avant
d'être en couple avec le champion
brésilien entre fit une relation avec le
chanteur colombien malouma connu en
france pour son featuring avec maître
gims un chanteur qui aurait eu du mal à
digérer la relation il faut dire que
malouda semble toujours amoureux de
natalia dans son dernier single hawaï
un couple et serait même dédié à la
relation entre natalia et neymar
[Musique]
tec est une chanson que démarre n'a pas
hésité à moquer sur les réseaux sociaux
en la reprenant de bon coeur avec ses
amis comme un pied de nez au chanteur un
pic qui semble avoir fonctionné puisque
malouda a décidé de quitter instagram du
jour au lendemain sans prévenir
visiblement atteint par cette attaque
autre histoire autres champions cette
fois ci avec kylie à la map et qui
semble lui aussi avoir trouvé l'amour et
pas auprès de n'importe qui puisque le
jeune homme serait quant à lui tombé
amoureux de l'ex copine de neymar selon
la presse il ne fait aucun doute que
kilian serait en couple avec le
mannequin français cindy brune à un
switch de partenaires qui n'a pas fini
de faire parler décidément au psg les
chaises musicales semble être un sport
de prédilection
[Musique]
cette histoire je vois qu'à intéresse
alors ce que fait malouma le fameux
chanteur noël dont on parle c'est pas
bien du tout et je vous ai expliqué
pourquoi il a voulu faire une carrière
de footballeur à ses inscrits en jeu
suit durant bâlois s'est inscrit en
juniors en colombie huit ans
ça n'a jamais marché et depuis même si
les chanteurs c'est un peu sa seconde
passion il jalouse neymar il provoque
neymar il apposait qu'un maillot du
bayer non mais il doit l'excellent
réseau et donc le volet ça mais je vous
dire qu'en allant m'énerver j'étais ado
à faire pour la violer oui la question
c'est est-ce qu'ils étaient copains
parce que ça c'est pas de piquer la
copine d'alors à 2 sa troisième femme
était la meuf de son meilleur ami il
était plus vraiment ensemble
mais j'avais quand eric chelle sa
personne
[Rires]